>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD, HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
SLAMMED TODAY AS AN
INSURRECTIONIST IN A SUIT AND
TIE.
THAT COMING FROM HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
DEMOCRAT ADAM SCHIFF PART OF THE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE
DEADLY INSURRECTION.
FOUR PEOPLE IN TRUMP'S INNER
CIRCLE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SUMMONED TO TESTIFY UNDER OATH.
STEVE BANNON SAYS HE'S NOT GOING
TO SHOW UP.
JOINING US, PAULA REID.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO THOSE
WHO DECIDE TO NOT COMPLY WITH
CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENAS.
>> ACCORDING TO SCHIFF, PEOPLE
WHO DON'T COOPERATE CAN GO TO
JAIL.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T OBSERVE THEIR
SUBPOENAS ARE GOING TO BE
REFERRED FOR CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
AND THE COMMITTEE IS PREPARED TO
URGE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
PROSECUTE ANYONE WHO REFUSES TO
COMPLY WITH SUBPOENAS FROM THE
PANEL.
NOW THERE ARE SOME SIGNS OF WHAT
COULD POTENTIALLY BE PROGRESS.
SCHIFF SAID TODAY THE COMMITTEE
IS ENGAGING WITH LAWYERS FOR
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS AND FORMER PENTAGON
OFFICIAL KASH PATEL TO TRY TO
SECURE THEIR TESTIMONY.
AS YOU NOTED, LONGTIME TRUMP
ADVISER STEVE BANNON HAS
INDICATED HE'LL NOT APPEAR UNTIL
A JUDGE RESOLVES QUESTIONS ABOUT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
NOW BANNON WAS NOT PART OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AT THE TIME IN
QUESTION AND HIS BLANKET REFUSAL
TO COOPERATE IS UNLIKELY TO HOLD
UP.
HE'S SCHEDULED FOR A DEPOSITION
ON THURSDAY.
IF HE MAKES GOOD ON HIS THREAT
NOT TO SHOW, JUST HOW FAST COULD
A CRIMINAL REFERRAL HAPPEN?
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> DAYS, WEEKS, MONTHS IN TERMS
OF WHEN THE CRIMINAL REFERRAL
WILL COME?
>> IT WILL COME VERY FAST IF
PEOPLE REFUSE TO COOPERATE.
>> SCHIFF NOTED UNLIKE THE PAST
FOUR YEARS, DEMOCRATS ARE NOW IN
CHARGE OF THE HOUSE AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WHILE TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE IT WAS
A LOT EASIER FOR ADVISERS LIKE
BANNON TO GET AWAY WITH
OBFUSCATION BECAUSE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS AND BARR WOULD
NOT PURSUE CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
BUT NOW THE DECISION ON WHETHER
TO PURSUE PROCEEDINGS WILL GO TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND.
SCHIFF WOULD NOT COMMENT ON
WHETHER THE TEAMS ALREADY
STARTED DRAFTING CRIMINAL
REFERRAL FOR STEVE BANNON BUT IT
IS EXPECTED THE COMMITTEE WILL
WAIT AT LEAST UNTIL THE END OF
THE WEEK AFTER THE DEADLINES
HAVE PASSED BEFORE PURSUING ANY
ADDITIONAL RECOURSE AGAINST ANY
WITNESSES WHO DON'T SHOW UP.
>> PAULA, TOMORROW ALSO IS A KEY
DEADLINE FOR OTHER SUBPOENAS,
RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, JAKE.
TRUMP ADVISERS ARE NOT THE ONLY
ONES WHO RECEIVED SUBPOENAS.
TOMORROW IS THE DEADLINE FOR A
GROUP OF PEOPLE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE JANUARY 6th RALLY TO TURN
OVER REQUESTED DOCUMENTS.
MULTIPLE SOURCES TELL CNN THAT
SEVERAL OF THOSE PEOPLE INTEND
TO COMPLY BUT THE COMMITTEE HAS
WARNED THAT ANYONE THAT DOES NOT
COULD FACE CONSEQUENCES UP TO
AND INCLUDING CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
>> PAULA REID, THANKS SO MUCH.
>>> ALSO IN OUR POLITICS LEAD,
NEW DETAILS ON THE ROLE PLAYED
BY A KEY HOUSE REPUBLICAN IN
SPREADING TRUMP'S BIG LIE.
A NEW SENATE REPORT INTO JANUARY
6th ZEROS IN ON TRUMP ALLY AND
PENNSYLVANIA REPUBLICAN SCOTT
PERRY.
HE'S A PROMOTER OF BASELESS
ELECTION LIES.
CONNECTIONS TO STOP THE STEAL
RALLIES.
DEMOCRATS IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CALLED THIS LITTLE
KNOWN CONGRESSMAN WHO REPRESENTS
THE HARRISBURG AREA A CRITICAL
PLAYER IN TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
HE WENT SO FAR AS TO VOTE TO
DISENFRANCHISE MILLIONS EVER HIS
FELLOW PENNSYLVANIANS ON THE DAY
OF THE INSURRECTION.
AS SARA MURRAY REPORTS, SENATE
DEMOCRATS SAY FURTHER
INVESTIGATION IS NEEDED TO PROBE
THE FULL SCOPE OF PERRY'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE RUN UP TO
THAT DEADLY DAY.
>> Reporter: THE PENNSYLVANIA
CONGRESSMAN TRUMPETED BASELESS
CLAIMS OF ELECTION FRAUD.
>> OFTENTIMES THEY SAY THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
FIRST OF ALL, WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH THERE IS.
>> Reporter: DONALD TRUMP WAS
LAUGHING THEM UP.
THE LOCAL OFFICIALS OR IN SCOTT
PERRY'S CASE, A FEDERAL
OFFICIAL, HAD ALL KINDS OF
INFORMATION ABOUT FRAUD AND
PROBLEMS AND THINGS THAT
IMPACTED THE ELECTION.
RICHARD DONAHUE TOLD THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NOW THE FIVE-TERM CONGRESSMAN
AND ARMY VETERAN IS FACING
SCRUTINY AS NEW DETAILS EMERGE
ABOUT HIS ROLE IN TRUMP'S PLOT
TO OVERTURN THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION RESULTS.
>> SCOTT PERRY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
SCOTT, THANK YOU.
>> Reporter: PERRY HAS SAID HE'S
UNAWARE OF ANY GOP LAWMAKERS
PLAYING A ROLE IN THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION.
>> I DON'T KNOW OF ANY.
WE'RE HERE AND OPEN FOR THE
INVESTIGATION.
IF PEOPLE ARE CULPABLE, THEY
NEED TO BE -- JUSTICE NEEDS TO
PREVAIL IN THAT REGARD.
>> Reporter: BUT A REPORT FROM
THE DEMOCRAT-LED SENATE PANEL
SAYS TRUMP ALLIES, INCLUDING
PERRY, HAVE NOTABLE TIES TO
JANUARY 6th.
AND THESE TIES WARRANT FURTHER
INVESTIGATION.
>> HOW DOES THE PRESIDENT INCITE
AN ATTACK THAT WAS PREPLANNED
AND ALREADY UNDER WAY BEFORE HIS
SPEECH CONCLUDED?
>> AND THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING JANUARY
6th WANTS PHONE RECORDS OF
SEVERAL LAWMAKERS, INCLUDING
PERRY.
>> JEFF CLARK.
>> Reporter: PERRY ADMITTED
INTRODUCING HIM TO JEFFREY CLARK
TO LED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
CIVIL DIVISION.
HE ATTEMPTED A NEAR COUP OF
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP.
>> JEFFREY CLARK BECAME DONALD
TRUMP'S BIG LIE LAWYER.
>> Reporter: THE SAME DAY TRUMP
TOLD DOJ OFFICIALS TO JUST SAY
THE ELECTION WAS CORRUPT AND
LEAVE THE REST TO ME AND THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN.
>> STOP THE STEAL!
>> Reporter: TRUMP DISPATCHED
PERRY TO CONVINCE DONAHUE THE
ELECTION HAD BEEN STOLEN.
PERRYDONAHUE.
POTUS ASKED HIM TO CALL.
ACCORDING TO DONAHUE, PERRY
TALKED UP CLARK EFFECTIVELY
SAYING JEFF CLARK IS GREAT.
HE'S THE KIND OF GUY WHO COULD
REALLY GET IN THERE AND DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
AS FOR DONAHUE'S EMAIL SAYING,
CAN I SEND YOU STUFF?
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF EVIDENCE.
HE SENT A DOCUMENT OF DEBUNKED
CLAIMS LIKE THIS ONE.
>> OVER 205,000 MORE VOTES WERE
CAST IN PENNSYLVANIA THAN PEOPLE
WHO VOTED IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION.
>> Reporter: CLAIMS PERRY CLUNG
TO AS HE OBJECTED TO THE 2020
ELECTION RESULTS JUST HOURS
AFTER RIOTERS STORMED THE U.S.
CAPITOL.
>> SADLY, BUT RESOLUTELY, I
OBJECT TO THE ELECTORAL VOTES OF
MY BELOVED COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Reporter: AN OBJECTION HE
STILL STANDS BY AS HE CONTINUES
TO CAST DOUBTS ON THE ELECTION.
>> WOULD YOU VOTE THE SAME WAY
NOW?
>> I ABSOLUTELY WOULD.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IT'S ABOUT THE PROCESS.
>> Reporter: NOW IT'S STILL
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE WILL WANT TO TALK TO
SCOTT PERRY.
WE REACHED OUT TO HIS OFFICE
WITH A VARIETY